c'est une forme inédite de mobilisation
à l'heure de la pause repas entre midi
et deux c'est vénézuéliens ont cessé
leur activité quitter leurs bureaux
leurs maisons afin de crier leur
ras-le-bol affiches et surtout leur
soutien au projet de changement incarné
par coin de gouaille dos celui qui s'est
autoproclamé président et qui a appelé à
cette protestation
je proteste parce que je veux que mon
pays soit libre dehors les dictateurs a
cédé narco état
c'est la seule chose que je veux et je
vois one day document président les
opposants se sont rassemblés un peu
partout dans le pays
plus de 5000 points mobilisation selon
les organisateurs avec des
revendications très diverses
nous sommes sortis dans la rue pour
demander que l'aide humanitaire soit
apporter immédiatement en tant que
travailleurs de santé nous n'allons pas
continuer à permettre que nos patients
meurent dans les centres de santé
un vent d'espoir souffle chez tous les
opposants rebooster par l'appui
international dont bénéficie troy wahid
sa présidence reste bien évidemment tout
symbolique
il n'a aucune prise sur les institutions
et au premier chef sur l'armée
vénézuélienne
malgré ses appels du pied pour tenter de
la faire basculer dans son camp
soldat de la patrie ne tirez pas sur le
peuple que manifeste aussi pour vos
familles c'est un ordre soda de la
patrie c'est un homme
[Musique]
mais tout scénario pour mettre un terme
au pouvoir de nicolas maduro passe par
les forces armées et elles affichent
pour le moment un soutien sans faille à
leur commandant en chef
le venezuela est une terre de rebelles
je vais vous poser une question
vous voulez que règne l'impérialisme
nord américain
vous voulez m'accompagner dans cette
lutte pour la patrie sur son compte
twitter le président vénézuélien n'a
cessé aujourd'hui de diffuser ces images
d'allégeance il faur harnais
bolivarienne les soldats bolivarien les
sodas de chavez ne sont pas touchés par
un mot des virus nous ne sommes pas
touchés par le virus de la trahison
à l'image de ces deux présidents la
société vénézuélienne est tiraillé entre
deux camps irréconciliables
l'ingérence internationale vient
renforcer la polarisation et
l'enlisement
aucune issue pour le moment ne semble se
dégager les états unis essaient de jouer
la carte de l'étouffement économique
on sait néanmoins que le dénouement de
ces crises sera forcément militaires ou
politiques